MANDY WAITE: Welcome to
Google Developers
Live from Campus London.
I'm Mandy Waite.
I'm a developer advocate for the
cloud platform at Google.
EMMA JACKSON: I'm
Emma Jackson.
And I look after Google's
education
programs in emerging markets.
And this is the next in our
series of Women Techmakers.
We're delighted to have Trisha
Gee with us today.
Trisha is a developer at 10gen,
the MongoDB company.
She has expertise in Java high
performance systems, is
passionate about enabling
developer productivity, and
has a wide breadth of industry
experience from the 12 years
she's been a professional
developer.
She's a leader in the London
Java community and also
involved in graduate developer
community.
And welcome Trisha.
TRISHA GEE: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
It's great to have you along
to Women Techmakers.
So the first question is
basically just kind of find
out a bit more about you.
You work at 10gen--
TRISHA GEE: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: --just down the
road from here, just down the
road from Campus London.
Tell us a bit more about the
work that you do at 10gen.
TRISHA GEE: So, I'm a Java
developer at 10gen.
So 10gen make MongoDB.
It's one of the new
No-SQL databases.
And as many databases have, it
has a number of drivers for
developers to work to code their
application against.
Because you can't just talk
directly to database.
You've got to talk something
from your
application to the server.
And 10gen have got 12 maintained
drivers and a
number of other community
drivers in
12 different languages.
And I'm look after the Java one,
along with another guy.
So it's interesting because
we're working in an
environment of lots of different
languages, and I'm
used to working in a very
Java-y environment.
And it's really cool, because
you can learn some different
stuff off different languages,
different people with
different backgrounds.
MANDY WAITE: So what other
languages are you
working with at 10gen?
And which ones particularly
interest you
most other than Java?
TRISHA GEE: Well, so I work
quite closely with the C# guys
because the Java and C# drivers,
we want them to be
fairly similar.
We want them to feel the same.
So that's interesting, because
we've got a lot of
similarities.
But the C# platform has
some things that Java
doesn't have yet.
So, for example, they do have
some lambda type functions,
and Java won't get that 'til
the end of this year.
Like Node.js is really
interesting, because it's
single threaded and
asynchronous, and it's a
totally different
way of working.
But there's no reason that you
can't get Java to look a
little bit like Node.js
if you wanted to.
So you can borrow some stuff off
them in terms of how they
do their asynchronous
callback type stuff.
And then you look at some of
the dynamic languages.
And they work in an entirely
different way.
For the first time I actually
feel a little bit jealous of
them, because they've got real
flexibility as to how they
take stuff from one thing and
turn it into another.
Because as a driver, what you
do is you take it from here
and turn it into this.
Normally in enterprise
applications it
doesn't work that way.
You've got your Java
application.
Then you do your proper
domain driven design.
And you've got your domain
model, and you
code it all in Java.
And you shouldn't be turning
things from this into this,
because it means you've done it
wrong in the first place.
So when you're writing an
application where the only job
is to turn it from this into
this, you're like, oh, Java's
not really easy to do
that sort of thing.
You've got to worry about
garbage collection
and things like that.
So yes, for once I'm kind
of a little bit jealous.
MANDY WAITE: Little
bit jealous.
OK.
All right.
EMMA JACKSON: What actually
excites you about the work
that you're doing at the
moment with 10 gen?
TRISHA GEE: Well, I'm in a
lucky position actually.
I got hired at the point
in time when we want to
effectively rewrite the Java
driver, which is not really
what I signed up for.
I kind of signed up for doing
some Java stuff and some
evangelist type stuff.
So I've got this dual role where
I do coding like a real
developer and go out to
conferences and do
presentations and do blogging.
And I very much wanted
a role where I could
have those two things.
It's quite difficult to be taken
seriously by developers
when you're going out there and
talking to them if you're
not doing code as well.
So it's important to do both
things at the same time.
However, I didn't really realize
that we were going to
do a whole rewrite of the Java
driver, which is both a curse
and a blessing.
Because it's cool, because you
get to look at something which
is currently in use, that
real people are using.
And you've got a specification
there because you've got
something that already works.
But you get to do it the way
that you want to do it.
And that's really cool.
But it's quite a lot of work.
And also, we do have a lot of
people using the existing one,
and you don't want to
alienate those guys.
And you want them to be
able to migrate to
the new world order.
And you don't want them to say
nasty things about you.
MANDY WAITE: That's awesome.
OK.
So.
EMMA JACKSON: So, yeah, let's
talk a bit about how you got
to where you are in your career
at the moment-- so this
little path that you
took to get there.
And I guess it started
with your
degree in computer science.
What factored into that decision
to study that?
TRISHA GEE: I didn't want to.
I wanted to be an
astrophysicist.
EMMA JACKSON: Oh, wow.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, wow,
astrophysicist.
TRISHA GEE: I was really into
science fiction and stuff.
So I guess I was a bit of
a geek as a teenager.
And I wanted to go to Mars.
And I wanted to be
an astronaut.
And I knew that probably wasn't
really going to happen.
But I thought astrophysicist is
a good way to look into the
stars and find out about
the universe out there.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, definitely.
TRISHA GEE: So I did maths,
physics, and computer science
at A level thinking that that's
a good platform for
almost any degree that
you want to do.
I kind of came from a difficult
background.
It's not like family wise.
My parents are going
to kill me, no.
It was fine.
But when I did my GCSEs, I did
10 very different subjects.
I did maths and science
and English and
French and PE and art.
Now, almost no one else did well
in the art and the PE and
the maths and science
and English.
So I had 10 subjects, and I
got A's in all of them.
It's like, oh, well,
that's great.
But where am I going
to go from here?
And in terms of my sixth form
choices, I wanted to do
various other--
I would have liked to have
carried on with art
and things like that.
But in terms of actual career
prospects, I decided that
maths, physics, and something
else would allow me to choose
pretty much whatever
I wanted to.
So although it looks like you
are narrowing yourself down,
in actual fact I picked them
because it wouldn't force me
to narrow down very early on.
If I wanted to go on and do
journalism, I could probably
still go on and do journalism.
If I wanted to be an artist, I
probably didn't need a degree
in art, for example.
So I did maths, physics, and
computer science thinking that
maybe I can go on and be
an astrophysicist,
and that'd be awesome.
And physics was kind of hard.
And the maths was a bit like,
oh, well, it's just more
imaginary numbers.
I mean seriously, who needs
an imaginary number?
It's hard enough with
the real numbers.
MANDY WAITE: Matrixes.
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: My favorite.
TRISHA GEE: And all
that stuff.
And I did well enough in the
maths and physics, but I knew
I didn't want to do
that going on, so.
And the computing, it turned out
that I actually not only
was good at programming, but
I enjoyed the programming.
And it's fun, because it's a
bit like the maths and the
physics, because it has got
right and wrong answers, and
it's logical.
But it's a bit more fun than
that, because you can play
around and see, oh, no one's
ever done this before.
And I can try and do this.
And how about that?
And it was much more
exploratory.
And it was more creative.
So it allowed me to bring in
some of the creative stuff
from when I was doing writing
and when I was doing art, but
doing it in a logical fashion.
So I thought it was the
best of all worlds.
So that's why I picked
computer science.
But I picked computer
science and AI--
MANDY WAITE: And AI, yeah.
TRISHA GEE: --because I still
was liking my science fiction.
And I still wanted
to do something--
I didn't want to be
a programmer.
I wanted to do something cool
and interesting, and I didn't
think being a programmer
was cool and
interesting at the time.
MANDY WAITE: Well, OK.
EMMA JACKSON: Do you
think that now?
MANDY WAITE: That's really
interesting.
TRISHA GEE: Well, yeah.
Well, I mean that's it.
I didn't really realize.
I didn't really know what being
a programmer was about.
And I definitely didn't want
to sit behind a desk for 40
hours a week behind a computer,
because I was very
active, and I did
lost of sports.
And my dad's a basketball
coach.
I didn't want to be sat
down all the time.
I just wasn't that
sort of person.
I didn't want to be
a programmer.
But the thing that it does offer
you is this variety of
solving other people's problems
and telling the
computer to do something.
And when it finally gets around
to doing it, it's like,
yay, it did that cool thing.
And there's lots of--
like I said-- lots of
creativity, even if you're not
doing front-ends.
I was doing quite a lot
of front-end stuff
early on, web stuff.
But even if you're not doing
something graphical, you're
sort of thinking, how can
I shape this problem?
How can I fix this?
How do I design that?
You are sat behind a computer
when you're programming.
But that's not what
it's about.
It's about getting up at the
whiteboard and talking to your
colleagues.
And it's about collaborating
with people to say, look, I
need to do this.
But there's going to be
four of us doing it.
So how do we work together
to make this work?
It's about talking to the
business and saying, when you
said you wanted this, did
you really want that?
What is it you're
trying to do?
And how can I help you do
what you want to do?
So there's lots of this kind
of talking to people stuff
that you don't realize happens
when you're a programmer.
You sort of think you're
communing with the computer.
But you're not.
Communing with the computer is
the easy bit, right, because
it does what you tell it to
even if you tell it to do
something stupid, right?
But ultimately, that's
the logical bit.
You say do this, and
it says yes or no.
So that's kind of--
not mechanical--
but that's the easy bit.
The difficult bit is I told it
to do this, but did that guy
over there, is that what he
wanted, or did he really mean
something else?
So you have the difficult bit of
translating from the fluffy
human stuff into the easy,
logical computer stuff.
MANDY WAITE: So I guess this is
where one of my questions I
had kind of framed up was the
fact that you're a developer
and that there's a kind of
a difference between a
programmer and a developer.
TRISHA GEE: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: And so let's talk
about the difference between a
programmer and developer.
So being a developer is much
more holistic than actually
just cutting code
and programming.
It's more about testing,
debugging, writing.
But what else does the
role of developer
specifically mean to you?
TRISHA GEE: It means--
I hate this phrase--
it means being involved in all
aspects of the software
lifecycle, right?
And you see it on people's CV.
And I think if you're not
involved in all aspects of the
software lifecycle, then
you're not a developer.
You're just a programmer.
And it means talking
to users or maybe
your business analyst.
It depends on the size
the company.
It depends on what you're
trying to do.
It means talking to people,
finding out what they want.
It means figuring out some
sort of design or
specification.
It doesn't have to be a
big design document.
It could just be a whiteboard
design.
Will this fit your needs?
Does the team think this is
going to work with the
existing architecture?
That's kind of a different
sort of puzzle.
And then it's the
coding stuff.
And I've done a lot of pair
programming in my last place.
Pair programming is totally
different to programming on
your own because you're sat
physically next to the person.
And you have to not want
to kill each other.
You have to be able
to communicate.
You have to be able to
say, look, I'm trying
to do it this way.
And what I've got in my head is
this, this, and this, which
is quite difficult.
Because normally when
you're coding on
your own, you explore.
You don't really know exactly
what you're trying to achieve.
You just explore.
But when you're coding with
someone else, you need to be
able to at least attempt
to communicate--
well, I'm doing this because I
saw this, and I thought this,
and I was thinking
maybe about that.
And then that's great, because
they can tell you early on
something like, no, no actually,
that's not really
applicable because of this.
And you're like, oh, yeah, I
didn't think about that.
Or, oh, great idea.
Why don't you look over here?
Because I know something
over here is the
same sort of thing.
So being able to communicate
what you're doing while you're
typing is quite tricky.
And being able to negotiate
over the design as you're
coding it is tricky too because
you're like, I'm right.
No, I'm right.
And you're both right.
And there are good
and bad points.
One of the best things I thought
about pair programing
is that when I used to code on
my own, I'd be like, right,
I'm going to do it this way.
No, no, no.
No, I prefer it the
other way better.
I'm going to do it this way.
No, but what about
the third way?
And when you're coding, you
have those conversations
before you start typing
anything.
And then eventually,
you'll end up with
something a bit better.
But it's not the same as what
you think of as programming.
You have to have these
interpersonal skills.
And no one tells you you need
interpersonal skills as a
programmer.
In fact, they often tell
you the opposite.
It's not true.
You need to be able to
speak to people.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
Yeah.
Definitely.
I guess I'm just going to
quickly follow up with one of
my questions, because it's
kind of related.
So programmer/developer
is one kind of track
through computer science.
Was it evident to you while you
were going through your
computer science degree that
there are other ways you can
go within computer science other
than just developing and
programming?
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
I mean, at university, no.
It wasn't evident
to me at all.
And in actual fact, I was a
little bit depressed for a
while, because I was learning
Java at university.
And I thought, right, well
that's it, I'm going to be a
Java programmer for like
the rest of my life.
That's what I've been
trained to do.
And 12 years later, I am still
a Java programmer.
But that's not the point.
Many of my other friends left
university and started off
being Java programmers, because
those are the skills
we've been given.
But they've ended up being
technical authors.
Or they've ended up being
technical project managers.
Or they've ended up being BAs.
Or they've ended up
being programmers
in different languages.
Or they've ended up starting
their own company, or being a
consultant.
Consultancy is interesting,
because it means lots of
different things, right?
It can either be going in and
hand waving at people saying,
oh, you should think
about this.
Or it could be going on site,
working with a team, and doing
coding with them.
There are very different
sorts of roles
just in that one umbrella.
So it wasn't evident
to me at all.
And one of the things that
we've been doing in the
graduate developer community
is doing this
meet and mentor project.
So you get people in the
software industry at the
moment, and they go
into universities.
And we sit down with students,
and they ask us questions.
And often they don't really know
what questions to ask.
So you sort of seed it with
this is what I do.
This is what my job
really involves.
Do you have any more questions
around what it means to be a
Java developer?
And then I will often drop
in the conversation--
like because they'll be
thinking, I still don't know
what I want to be when I grow
up-- and then you'll say,
there are other paths.
There are other things
you can do.
And not just with computer
science.
Because at the end of the day,
you've got a degree.
And you've got a scientific-ish
degree.
So that opens up lots
of different paths.
And you can do a master's in
almost anything, right?
So you can cross train
to something else.
At least you got a degree.
MANDY WAITE: Well, thank you.
EMMA JACKSON: So thinking
about your path
to where you are--
I guess you started off wanting
to go to Mars, and you
ended up a Java developer.
But did you feel like you had
a plan once you went through
university and the steps that
you took, the career changes?
Or is it sort of happy
accidents--
TRISHA GEE: I sort of had an
iterative plan, really.
I mean, I still don't
know what I want to
be when I grow up.
I mean, it scared me when you
said I've got 12 years of
experience.
I'm like, oh, no.
That means I graduated
a long time ago.
EMMA JACKSON: You could
still get to Mars.
Don't worry.
TRISHA GEE: I could
still go to Mars.
I could send something
that goes to Mars.
So, no, I certainly didn't have
a "this is where I want
to be" or "this is what I want
to do." And even now, my
horizon's probably two years
out, maybe five.
There it gets--
you can be more directed within
six months to a year.
You got a good idea of
where you want to go.
And then two years, yeah.
And then five years,
well, is these--
I want to make sure I don't
cut off these options.
So I think the main thing I had
was, in terms of planning
my career, it was always try
not to cut things off.
Try not to exclude things, which
is why I picked my A
levels, which is why I picked
computer science, because it
wasn't going to stop me
following various paths.
And similarly, I did consultancy
for a while,
because I thought that
would open up a lot
more stuff to me.
And I could work in different
industries.
I could get a feel of how
different teams work.
I could get a feel for the
difference between working in
banking versus manufacturing
versus education.
And that way I have
more options.
So I guess my main career thing
has not been, I want to
get here, but I want to make
sure I can get there if I want
to, and there and there.
And the way you do that--
instead of being overwhelmed
by all those choices-- is,
well, where am I now?
What skills do I have?
What do I like doing?
And what can I do for the next
sort of one to two years which
will either move me closer
to a particular goal.
Or more likely, what am I going
to do in the next one to
two years which I enjoy doing?
Because that means then I'm
going to carry on enjoying
doing what I'm doing and
learning more about the stuff
I'm enjoying.
And so, if you're ever stuck,
you just think,
what do I like doing?
I don't like doing that.
Don't do it any more then.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
Yeah.
Good point.
So, I guess I have one kind of
question going back to what we
were talking about a little
while ago about CS and CS
skills in general.
So it seems that CS skills are
applicable in a multitude of
different roles nowadays.
You could be not just
technology.
I don't have any specific
examples other than maybe
finance and spreadsheets and
scripts and spreadsheets.
And scripting seems to be a
big thing that's becoming
fairly common nowadays.
But it seems that CS skills are
something that we should
be learning at a very early
age, being very young, and
maybe even broken out of
computer science completely,
the basic program and the
ability to put programs
together and to code things and
to control your world and
your environment from
technology.
So do you feel the same?
Do you feel similar?
Are we now at the point where CS
skills are vital for a wide
variety of different roles?
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
I mean, I would say yes.
I do agree.
I think what you said
was interesting.
I never really thought
about it that way.
How can we extract the really
reusable bits from CS?
It's a very computer science
thing to want to do, right,
extract the reusable stuff,
the usability.
But what is applicable?
Maybe programming, per
se, might not be.
But maybe algorithms generally
is quite useful.
I did some psuedocoding back
when I was still 16 doing
algorithmic stuff.
And, it's a definitely reusable
skill to be able to
think, right, I have
a particular
problem that needs solving.
I have a particular set
of skills and a
particular set of tools.
So maybe it's Excel, or
maybe it's Office.
Or maybe it's I've got friends
over there I can
call who can do stuff.
And the ability to break down
the steps needed to get from
here to here--
whether it's because you're
trying to plan your wedding or
because you're trying to
organize your team or whether
it's because you're trying
to write a program--
those sorts of skills are
definitely useful.
But I also think that
things like--
I mean, I think the
mathematical
logic stuff is useful.
And I think data structure is
absolutely fundamental if
you're going to do anything
even slightly computer
sciencey, but probably
not so reusable.
But I think that sort of thing
should be taught in school.
And the UK government's been
doing some stuff around that
area in terms of changing
the focus from
ICT to computer science.
And I think that's the
right thing too.
I think technical skills
are really important.
I think you should be able
to type for start, right?
And I think you should be able
at use Word and PowerPoint and
Excel and things.
Excel, in particular, is used in
a lot of different places.
But I think teaching computer
science as a separate thing to
ICT is important, because
learning to use a tool is one
thing, but learning to create
the tool is an entirely
different set of skills.
And I think that we as
developers and as technical
professionals, we need to help
teachers teach that, because
they don't have the time to.
We spent 10 years developing
these skills, right?
We know them.
We do them day in, day out.
And teachers, they
teach very well.
They do that day in, day out.
But they have to
teach all these
different subjects, right?
MANDY WAITE: Right.
Yeah.
Exactly.
TRISHA GEE: And I think if
you're going to teach computer
science well, you need to get
computer scientists in to
teach computer science well.
So I think it's a really good
idea to try and reach out to
schools and say, do
you need any help?
I can offer you some hours
per week to do that.
MANDY WAITE: In terms of
volunteer programs.
That kind of thing.
Yeah.
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Sharing your
abilities and your knowledge
with students and such.
Really cool idea.
I mean, we do some of that
at Google already.
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
There's lots of different
projects for it.
And that's the interesting
thing.
There's lots of little
seeds of ideas.
And I wonder if there's scope
at some point to be able to
start putting this together
and saying, if you want to
work in this area or in this
technology or with these
schools, then these are the
programs which are available,
and this is how you get in.
Because you have to do things
like you have to have your CRB
check, and you need to be
cleared to work with kids and
things like that.
It'd be great to have some
central place to say, how do I
get involved with this
sort of thing?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
Some kind of registry
or something like
that where you say--
some kind of volunteer registry
where you can say,
I'm able to to do this.
I'm able to supply these
kind of skills and--
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
Like a sort of match.com for--
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
TRISHA GEE: --for schools
of computer science.
MANDY WAITE: Some of us are
actually scared of actually
standing in front of a classroom
of children and
being exposed to that and having
your primal instincts
kind of like challenged.
TRISHA GEE: Of course.
MANDY WAITE: This is my
nightmare, standing in front
of a group of children.
And they can ask me questions
I can't answer.
TRISHA GEE: Exactly.
And kids don't really have the
same sort of barriers that
adults have.
They'll ask all sorts
of stuff.
I mean, that's the stuff
that teachers are
really good at, right?
So that's what we can learn
off the teachers.
And the teachers can
learn some computer
science stuff off us.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
OK.
Excellent.
EMMA JACKSON: This is a good
idea for a new start-up, the
match.com of technology
professionals in schools.
That's good.
TRISHA GEE: Obviously
integrated with Google AdWords.
EMMA JACKSON: Of course.
Yes.
So while we're talking about
education actually, I was
thinking there's been so many
advancements in technology for
education lately, things like
these massive open online
courses and things like
this and apps
you can get for education.
What are your thoughts
on this and how it's
changing how we educate?
TRISHA GEE: I think
it's amazing.
My parents are teachers, so I'm
really interested in the
education side of stuff.
And I think that--
I've got so many thoughts going
through my head, I don't
know how to face them all.
So 10gen are running online
education for
MongoDB at the moment.
They ran a course
using Python.
And we're now running
one using Java.
So it's definitely something
that me and my day job, I'm
actually recently involved in.
And we've found it very,
very useful, because
it scales much better.
Now, we could hire a bunch of
consultants, teach them how to
teach MongoDB, teach them how
to teach developers how to
code, and then we could
sell those consultants
into places of work.
And we could make loads
of money off that.
But it's not very scalable.
And the ability to make sure
that all your consultants are
teaching the same sort of thing,
the consistency, the
branding, it's a little
bit more difficult.
And actually if you're a
software firm, sure you could
make money doing that, but it's
probably not the best
thing to do.
So as a software firm, what you
should do is provide an
online training platform.
You could charge for it if you
wanted to, but why should you?
Because the point is you're
training people up on how to
use your technology.
And if people want to use your
technology and know how to use
it properly, your support
costs are lower.
They're using your technology.
They're spreading the word and
saying that you're amazing.
It's just a very, very
good thing to do.
And like I said,
it's scalable.
You can put this online course
there with lectures.
And then really the interaction
is you can still
have emails and things
like that.
So you still need people
at the end of the line.
But you don't have to send
someone in to train someone
for like a week.
So from a corporate point of
view, it's almost a no-brainer
if you can invest
the time in it.
From like a more widespread
point of view, the internet
opens up so much
for us, right?
We could do so much now.
We can learn stuff we never
could have learned before.
We can find out about things
we never could have found
about before.
Things like the Open University
stuff has totally changed.
You don't have to get
loads of packets of
information, pieces of paper.
You can do it online.
And you can do stuff
in your own time.
And I think it allows you to
improve yourself and educate
yourself at your own pace.
And I think anything which is
about learning and improving
is a good thing.
I've been approached by a bunch
of people about creating
software for home schooling
kids, particularly in America.
And I find that really, really
interesting too.
I'm not sure how much I agree
with that, because I think
kids need to learn how to
interact with people.
I think that's the most
important thing
you learn at school.
I don't think it's maths
and science.
I think it's how people are
different to your family unit.
And you need to learn to
negotiate with those people
and play nicely with others.
But if we're worried about
consistency of teaching in
schools across the UK or across
the US or whatever, you
can plug some of those holes
by providing some home
schooling stuff or some online
education stuff.
And it doesn't matter, then,
where you live or what school
your kid goes to or even
necessarily what background
you're from.
You can provide your kid with
opportunities to improve
themselves and move on and do
stuff they couldn't have done
20 years ago.
So I think it's really
exciting.
And I'm using Rosetta Stone to
learn Spanish at the moment.
And that's amazing.
It's very well designed.
It's a very well designed
piece of software.
And I keep thinking in my head,
I'm like, I wonder how
they did this?
And it's really amazing how
they've planned the material
to be really sensibly
organized.
And I'm reporting bugs as well--
that doesn't work.
I've been thinking about
learning a new
language for 10 years.
And being able to put aside the
same hour of every week to
go to a class to learn it is
never going to happen.
Even before I was traveling all
over the world, that was
just never going to happen.
Because sometimes on a Thursday
at 6 o'clock, I might
not want to.
I might want to have pizza and
sit at home and watch tele.
So I think the online stuff
just allows you to be more
flexible about learning.
MANDY WAITE: So I guess you
talked earlier about--
offline--
you talked about gamification,
and also one other thing would
be the social aspects of
education materials, things
like Rosetta Stone where you can
interact with other people
online, people who may be at the
same level as you, people
that you can speak with
and practice and
converse with there.
That's really interesting.
So, do you do much of the social
interaction side on
Rosetta Stone with
other people?
TRISHA GEE: No, because I say,
oh, I'm going to meet with my
Spanish friends, and I'm going
to talk Spanish to those guys,
which I don't.
But the fact that it is there.
And the fact that you could sort
of speak to someone who
knows that you're a loner, who's
there to help you and
correct you if necessary, I
think that's a good thing, if
you like that sort of thing.
Me, I'm a bit shy.
And I'm like, I don't want
to speak to someone
in my rubbish Spanish.
I'd rather speak
to the machine.
And that's one of the other
good things about online
learning is that you can guide
according to what your
preferences are.
Me, I don't want to talk
to real people.
So when I talk to the machine,
it's much better.
MANDY WAITE: One down side of
that is that ultimately when
you're going to speak Spanish,
you're going to be speaking to
other people [INAUDIBLE].
TRISHA GEE: I know.
But I'll cross that bridge
what I get good enough to
speak to those people.
MANDY WAITE: And just quickly
mention as well, the Open
University, I'm up on
the Open University
for like five years.
TRISHA GEE: Right.
MANDY WAITE: Their materials
and their website and such
like is so well up
to date now.
The materials out there-- they
have Android applications and
iOS applications for
reading material.
So they're really up to speed.
They've done a great job of
making things happen.
And I know they're kind of
resource constrained and
struggling to get budget
and such like.
But they're doing a really,
really good job.
TRISHA GEE: I think having the
different platforms is really
interesting as well.
I wanted to pick a language
learning tool that I could use
on my phone, on my iPad,
and on my laptop.
And the only thing that I'm
struggling with is that most
of them don't work offline.
And of course in London on the
Tube, you're not online.
And so lots of iPad apps are
great because most of them are
designed to work
on and offline.
And then you can just
do it like, oh,
I've got five minutes.
I'm on the train, and I'll read
this, or I'll do this
exercise or whatever.
And I think that's something
we didn't
have three years ago.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
At the same time, I'm
learning Japanese.
And I have like six or seven
applications on my Android
phone that I use constantly when
I'm in situations like
standing up on the train--
TRISHA GEE: Right.
MANDY WAITE: --and I want
to just quickly test my
vocabulary or practice my verbs
and that kind of thing,
I just fire up the application
and just stand and do
something useful with
that time--
TRISHA GEE: Right.
MANDY WAITE: --which otherwise
would have been wasted.
TRISHA GEE: Yeah, actually.
You'd just be playing Sudoku
on your phone,
which is what I'm doing.
And you wouldn't open up your
laptop and get started on
something which is really--
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
Yeah.
Not if you're standing
up definitely.
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
It just changes the way
that you learn.
It changes everything.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Yeah.
It's fantastic.
So I guess on that same
subject-- and I think that
question is kind of a follow up
to this one, but I think we
can still talk about it-- is
technology is [INAUDIBLE].
I think you said it permeates
everything that we do.
It's used to build the fabric
for our clothes.
These fibers that we have in
our clothes are crazy.
And they're all nanotechnology,
that kind of thing.
It's used to process our food.
Hopefully, beef, maybe,
and not horse meat.
It's used to condition
our air.
And computer science is really
enabling technology
everywhere.
And it's no longer just about
creating large software
applications such as
Microsoft Office.
Computer science and technology
is about a much
larger thing.
It's kind of permeating
everything that we do.
So what do you see as the role
of computer science in the
modern world--
TRISHA GEE: Well--
MANDY WAITE: --not
just education?
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
I mean I think you
kind of said it.
It's that it's everywhere.
It impacts everything.
It impacts where you're going
to dig a well in Africa.
It impacts, like you say,
how your clothes
are designed or how--
I mean, I don't think IKEA could
be as cheap for tables
if they didn't have-- like
they've obviously got CAD
software, but they've probably
got also really cool--
I've seen this at Ford--
they've got cool pieces of
software which design the way
that you're going to plug stuff
together, tells you the
order in which you should plug
stuff together, and then can
create a manual for that
sort of thing.
And this is the sort of thing
that allows you to then hire a
particular type of person to be
able to do that very easily
or to sell it to people and
say, look, that's just go.
It's just there for you.
And computer science that's done
right makes all of our
lives easier, right?
But it does mean that there's
actually going to be more and
more computer science type jobs,
and they're all going to
be really different
sorts of jobs.
So I think that was a worry
maybe in then '90's, maybe in
some of the noughties, that when
we come from coding BASIC
in the '80s, it was kind of you
knew you could write your
little application.
It might be a game, or it
might be something.
And you could sort of hold the
whole thing in your head and
code it all in BASIC, and
you're sort of done.
In the '90s, things got bigger
and more modular when we
started coding, and we
started using PCs.
So you couldn't always see what
was under the covers.
You couldn't just type BASIC
into the command line.
And there was this kind of
concern that computer science
was getting so big and almost so
enterprise that there's no
way you could start really
easily write a little thing
and grow from there.
Because you were going to have
to be working on Microsoft
Word or some banking payroll
application, or it was going
to be some big enterprise
thing.
I think that everything has
changed in the last decade,
maybe, because what we've seen
is that some of those things
have got bigger, and we've
got these platforms.
These things go up here, and
then something has to fill
that space.
And then these things grow
over here into clothing
technology.
Or into home automation.
How cool is that?
I can get my iPad, and
I can like open my
curtains from work.
I don't know why I'd need to do
that, but I might need to.
And this is crazy cool stuff.
And Raspberry Pi and
all these things.
And it allows you to--
if you're interested in
mechanical stuff, because I
know some people find
the computer
science a bit abstract--
if you want to see something
happen, you can do robotics
and Raspberry Pi and
home automation.
If you want to do something
which is quick and visual, you
could do like a Facebook game,
or you could do Android apps
are quite easy to write
and things like that.
But if you want to do something
like really more
mathematical and abstract, you
could go and write the
matching engine in
a bank somewhere
or a trading algorithm.
It's just so much.
Whatever you want to do, there's
going to be something
there that interests you.
I think that's a message which
isn't really getting across.
I think we still think of
programmers as sort of sitting
down and writing Java code and
writing payroll applications
for banks instead of
thinking about, you
know, I don't know--
like I said, the home automation
stuff is cool.
I just think that's awesome,
being able to almost program
your own house to do whatever
it wants to, take over the
world, I don't know.
MANDY WAITE: I guess we've had
conversations about the
creative aspect of computer
science as opposed to
programming being of itself just
something that you do as
being a means to an end.
You know, actually there's
something you
can build from it.
It's like knitting or crochet
or Lego bricks.
You can actually build
something with it.
I think there's always been this
kind of illusion that you
can just program.
And it didn't have to have an
end goal or have a goal.
But now people are using
it to be creative.
And I think the more of that
that you see everywhere, the
better it will get, and the
more things will change.
And more people will see that
the options when it comes to
choosing roles within
computer science are
much more varied now.
TRISHA GEE: I think
this is one of my
long-term stretch goals.
I would like Hollywood to change
the image of computer
programmers.
Because I think they still
portray people as being coding
for the sake of coding or some
sort of magician who does his
magic thing over here and no one
else-- and when I say his,
I obviously mean his--
magic thing over there and no
one else will understand that.
No one else understands me,
because I'm a magic, secret
computer programmer.
And I'd like to see people
express how creative it is and
how you can do something because
your mom says I really
need something to help
map my family tree.
And you can write a
family tree app in
whatever you want to.
I need something which is
like, I don't know--
like recipe apps.
I think they're kind of cool.
Sounds pretty girly,
doesn't it?
No, but, like--
MANDY WAITE: But
they are cool.
They are cool.
TRISHA GEE: I would love to see
something where you say,
right, I've got these things
in my cupboard.
Can you tell me what
I can make?
And it'll tell you you can make
a Victoria spongecake
with cheese on top.
That's not quite what
I wanted, but--
Yeah.
I think it's very,
very creative.
I'd like more people to be aware
of how creative it is.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
OK.
EMMA JACKSON: So we talked a
little bit about when you were
talking about your career
path and how you got
from where you are.
And it sounded like you've
made these really wise
decisions along the way to sort
of keep your options open
and not to be tied down into
these kind of areas.
But has there been someone
that's influenced your life?
What's the best advice you've
been given to help you make
those decisions?
TRISHA GEE: I had
lots of advice
along the way, obviously.
And each bit of advice was the
best advice, given my position
at that moment in time and for
where I was going to go.
So there's two examples,
actually, because in some ways
they're the same, and in some
ways they're different.
When I started, I worked
at Ford Motor Company.
And there were a lot of guys
there who were from various
consultancies, because they're
one of these large
organizations that gets
consultants into help them.
And one of the consultants said
to me-- this was my very
first placement.
I was still at university.
So it was my three-month
vacation placement.
And he said, if you want to get
ahead, you have to play a
bit of politics.
And I'm like I'm this geek girl
programmer who like likes
science fiction and the logical
bit of computers, but
also I'm a creative
artistic type.
I don't want to play politics.
That's exactly what I
don't want to do.
I don't want to play games
and things like that.
But he kind of explained
it to me.
And he said, look, you're in a
difficult position, because
you're sat behind a computer
all day every day.
And you could be doing the best
work ever, you could be
doing the worst work ever, and
no one will know unless you
tell people.
You're going to have to tell
people that you're good.
And I'm like, yeah, but
what if I'm not good?
He said, it doesn't matter.
If you want to get on, you're
going to have to tell people
what you're good at and
how good you are.
And of course, being the sort
of person who doesn't really
lie about things like that, then
I'll tell them the things
I'm good and the things
I'm bad at.
And to me that translated to
actually just being visible.
So getting involved in--
because I was one of the
undergraduates at Ford, we
used to rotate between
placements.
So I helped some of the
placement rotation.
And that was self-serving,
because I wanted to make sure
I got a good placement.
But it was also self-serving
because management would see
these undergraduates are helping
with the process, and
they have these skills to be
management material or whatever.
So I got more involved with that
sort of thing just for
the visibility.
And it ended helping my career,
not just for the
visibility but because
I got a bit more
control over my career.
Because I was in a position
where I could
influence my own career.
So that was good.
And I learned that politics
does matter if you're a
programmer.
And that's kind of depressing.
But I'm sorry, but that's
just the way it is.
The other best piece of advice
I have which changed my life
in the last two years is I was
complaining about one of the
conferences--
when would this be?
Maybe three years ago,
maybe two years ago.
Not that long ago.
One of the conferences only
had white men speaking.
And actually, there was a woman,
but she didn't have her
icon up there.
So you couldn't see her
face in this whole
sea of white males.
So I was complaining about
this to Martin Fowler who
works at ThoughtWorks.
And he'd come over to
ThoughtWorks UK, and he was
meeting with a few people.
And I was really star struck,
because I'm like, this is like
Martin Fowler.
He's written books
and everything.
And I was complaining
about this thing.
And he said, well, why don't
you volunteer to speak?
And I was like, well.
He said, well, look.
You're in absolutely the right
position to change that.
You are a female technical
person.
And the conference organizers
don't think they've excluded
people like you on purpose.
If you go to them and say, can
I talk, and they say no, then
you can start saying, oh, these
people are really unfair.
But don't just complain to me in
a pub about there not being
enough women speakers
when you're a woman.
I was like, oh, OK.
So by the end of that year
another colleague-- my boss,
actually-- was speaking
at Java One.
And he said, do you want
to come up and
co-present with me?
And I was like, no,
don't be silly.
And because of what Martin
Fowler had said and because of
the original comment about
being visible and about
telling people--
giving visibility on what you
may or may not be good at and
because it scared
the absolute--
I was like that sounds like a
really terrible thing to do--
I said yes, and I did it.
And that's why I am where I am
right now, because I decided,
oh, this is quite-- it's not
easy by any means-- but this
is quite good actually.
And you get to travel and meet
people and talk to them.
And that's as much fun as
programming in some ways.
And that's how I
got my new job.
MANDY WAITE: I think it's kind
of something that's kind of
ingrained in us when
we're young that we
can't change things.
The world is the way it
is, and we can't do
anything about it.
And I think my time at Google,
I've found that I can actually
change things--
and probably for the first time
in my life-- that I can
say, we're not doing
this right.
Let's do it differently.
And people would listen
and take action.
I think it's something that it
takes a long time and a lot of
experience to realize what
you can actually do.
And it probably takes some
successes as well.
You can probably
get frustrated.
I need to change that.
I can't change it.
There's no way for
me to change it.
But then when the opportunity
comes along and you take it,
then it can be really enabling,
because suddenly you
realize you can change pretty
much everything.
It can be pretty [INAUDIBLE].
TRISHA GEE: Yeah, exactly.
And I think that as technical
programming type people, we're
almost exactly the right people
to change things.
We're used to taking a piece
of code and changing it or
getting it to work in
a different way.
We're used to systems
thinking.
We're used to thinking, OK, this
goes to this goes to this
goes to this consequently
that.
Oh, that's not right.
Let's do this.
And we're exactly the right
people to go, OK, so if this
is what's happening, if this is
how things work, it doesn't
have to work that way.
My job is to change stuff,
whether it's at the byte level
or whether it's people level.
If you present to people
sometimes the system that has
led to this conclusion and say,
well, you know what, if
we did this bit a little
bit differently,
things might change.
People will go, oh, OK.
But as you said, successes
are kind of important.
And the first few times
you do that--
first many times you do that--
chances are pretty good
someone will say what
do you know.
And then that's fine,
because you haven't
proved anything yet.
You just have to keep
doing until you
get a couple of successes.
And then when you've got a few
successes you say, well, I
don't know anything about
it, but I did this over
here, and it worked.
Just keep going.
MANDY WAITE: I think that brings
me onto one of the
questions I kind of pulled from
your bio because you said
something that is obviously
important to you.
You believe that people
shouldn't always have to make
the same mistakes
again and again.
So my question to you is do
you mean that by this we
should learn from our own
experiences, or do you mean
that through sharing, knowledge,
and experience we
can help others not to make the
same mistakes again and
again and again?
TRISHA GEE: Well,
both of course.
I mean, how often do you kick
yourself when you've made the
same mistake the third time?
I don't necessarily mean
mistyping the wrong thing.
It might be mistyping
the wrong thing.
Or it might be--
MANDY WAITE: Remove
minus r star and--
TRISHA GEE: Yeah.
Oh, god.
I've done that.
I've done that in a--
MANDY WAITE: You only
do that once.
TRISHA GEE: --production--
Yes, you only do that once.
I've done that in a
production-like environment,
and I've never made the
same mistake again.
So, yeah.
I mean, you always want to learn
from your own mistakes.
And it might be dumb stuff like
I came into work when I
was feeling ill again, and I'm
not doing anything again.
Next time I'm not going
to do that.
But I feel quite a lot like I've
learned a lot of things
the hard way.
I mean, I've had good
advice from various
people along the way.
But like I said, it always seems
to be sort of just in
time advice.
And I kind of feel like some
of the stuff that I learned
the hard way without that
advice, I'd like to tell
graduates or undergraduates
or kids that stuff now.
Not like everything.
I don't need to download
12 years of
experience into their brains.
Because I was always
on this sort of
one to two year horizon.
I was always frantically trying
to take chances to make
sure they didn't escape.
I have to do this, this, this,
and this because I might never
get a chance to do
it ever again.
And it's not true, because
you'll come back later.
Your career works in cycles and
your life works in cycles.
And a chance, if it's
the right chance,
will come up again.
Or it disappears off the radar,
and it turns out it
wasn't that important anyway.
I'd like to share with people,
yeah, lots of stuff I kind of
learned the hard way.
But it's not like this is how
you do domain-driven design.
It's more like this is what you
might want to bear in mind
when you manage your career.
Not like this is how you
manage you're career.
But, don't worry about this.
Do worry about that.
This is important.
MANDY WAITE: The kind
of Confucian wisdom.
It's like you're kind
of making a point.
And that you can apply this to
your life in some way, but
it's not a kind of rigid thing
that you have to kind of
adhere to completely.
TRISHA GEE: Right.
It's much more like a set
of things that have you
considered this?
Did you think about that?
If there is a question, your
correct answer might be yes or
your correct answer might be no,
but the point is did you
consider the question?
MANDY WAITE: OK.
EMMA JACKSON: I like
that approach.
I know you're talking about
learning from mistakes.
It's probably things that-- we
talked about successes and how
that propels you forward some
way, but often you probably
learn more from your
failures than your
successes in a lot of ways.
And it's good to share that
with others and--
MANDY WAITE: Absolutely.
TRISHA GEE: I think so.
And in fact, I proposed a track
at QCon London called--
well, it was going to be called
Learning From Failure,
because when you go
to conferences--
and I've been to a few in
the last year or so--
you get a lot of people saying,
we did this this way,
and it worked.
And you're like, great,
but we're not you.
We don't have your team.
We don't use those
technologies.
What lessons am I going
to take from
this particular thing?
So I said how about we have a
few brave souls step up and
say, we did this, and it was
rubbish, and we tried that,
and it didn't work?
We experimented with this
technology, and it didn't work
for us because--
not like this technology's
rubbish, but because we didn't
consider the business needs,
or our team wasn't
skilled on it, or--
And I think that it's much
easier to learn from those
things than it is--
because I reckon for every
success, there's got to be, I
don't know, 90 failures.
Even if it's two failures, the
number of failures massively
outweighs the number
of successes.
And learning from that one
success that happened in one
time and at one place with
those people, you can't--
if you reproduce what
happened to get
there, you'll get there.
And they're already there.
You don't want to be there.
You want to be where
you want to be.
So you want to make sure that
you don't do the failure stuff
that happened around
those cases.
EMMA JACKSON: Yeah.
I like to talk about that too,
because, I don't know, you
might get disheartened if you
sort of try something that
doesn't work, and you make these
mistakes and just to not
let it set you back.
That's a key piece
of going forward.
TRISHA GEE: It's as an easy
thing to say to say, oh, don't
worry about it.
But like, but I am
worried about it.
And you should worry about it.
Because if you don't think about
it, you will make the
same mistake again.
But I think this is particularly
important for--
this is going to be a gross
generalization and
stereotype--
but for British people
because the
Americans are a bit better.
Americans, specifically, are a
bit better at understanding
that success comes
with a price.
And you could have nine start-up
failures, and the
10th one might be
the right one.
And they're OK with that.
They're kind of OK with trying
again and again and again.
I think for the Brits, if you
fail one, it's like, oh, well.
If you fail twice, it's like,
well, you're never going to
get anywhere, right.
And I think that we should be
much better at saying, yes,
but the second time I failed,
I didn't fail
for the same reason.
And the third time I fail,
it'll be for a different
reason again, and to see that
incremental change.
MANDY WAITE: Interesting.
Yeah.
OK.
So I guess one other question
I have, probably the last
question, is talking about
role models, which is
primarily for me one of the
main reasons we do Women
Techmakers is present people
with role models.
So how do you think we can do
more to establish, using
programs like Women Techmakers
and such like that, establish
role models, aspirational
people, to young people
looking to decide whether to get
into technology, to choose
technology as an educational
path or career path?
What more can we do to establish
role models for
young people?
TRISHA GEE: I think there's
two sides to it.
I think lots of organizations,
lots of communities, lots of
educational groups are very keen
on creating and promoting
role models-- well, not creating
them, finding them
and promoting them.
But I think that the thing that
I've been trying to tell
people is to tell people that
they are role models.
Because you get people saying,
yes, I think we should have
more women.
Or yes, we should have less
white people at the top.
And I'm like, yeah, but
you're a woman.
Do you want to come and talk
at this conference?
No.
I mean, I don't even want to
really talk about the race
thing because we're all like
white, right, but if people
start complaining about their
particular minority being not
well represented, like I was
complaining about no women
speakers, then it's really
up to you to step up and
represent that--
well, OK, so yes you can
represent that minority.
And one of the things that makes
me really uncomfortable
is every time someone asks me to
speak for women developers.
OK, yeah, but I can't
really do that.
I can speak for me.
And I am a woman developer,
and some people might find
that what I say is the truth.
And some people might go,
I completely disagree.
If someone completely disagrees
with my viewpoint
and completely disagrees with
me representing women
techmakers, then I would love
to see them step up and
represent their viewpoint.
And that's great.
It gives you the balance
and say there's
more than one of us.
We do lots of different
things.
So I think people need to step
up the same way I was
told to step up.
I think that you can do it.
It is important.
And you are a role model.
And you're a role model probably
because you're not
like everyone else, probably
because there isn't someone
out there who looks like you.
And if you step up and you are
that role model, you get to
represent your viewpoint.
It's the same thing I said about
the getting involved in
the rotations thing, right?
By stepping up and representing
your viewpoint
and having a voice, you get to
change things so that it works
for you, right?
So you could do it for all those
people who want to look
at you and be a role model if
you want, but basically it's
good for you.
MANDY WAITE: Completely.
Yeah.
EMMA JACKSON: It's great
inspiring words to end on.
MANDY WAITE: So I guess my last
point is when are you
going to Mars?
I want to go with you.
TRISHA GEE: Maybe next year.
MANDY WAITE: I'm really
keen to go to Mars.
Even if it's a one-way trip.
I'd probably go.
TRISHA GEE: I know.
I thought about terraforming
Mars.
How cool would that be and
being like a colonist?
That'd be awesome.
But I actually spoke to
some NASA people at--
when was that--
[INAUDIBLE] last year.
They had some NASA people coming
in doing some of the
coding for kids at
[INAUDIBLE].
And I was like, can I
have a job in NASA?
Please, please, please?
And they said, do you have
an American green card?
I said no.
Oh, well.
We do have some people in some
university in London doing
some coding.
I said, yeah, but I don't really
want to be stuck in
some university in London doing
some coding, not that
there's anything wrong
with that.
I want to go to Mars.
MANDY WAITE: You should join
the British space program.
TRISHA GEE: Didn't they collapse
that a few years ago?
MANDY WAITE: They
may have one.
We should have one.
We should have a secret one.
TRISHA GEE: We should
have one.
MANDY WAITE: We should
probably form one.
TRISHA GEE: That's
my next startup.
EMMA JACKSON: Yeah.
That would be good.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Well, brilliant.
So, thank you ever
so much, Trisha.
It's been really wonderful
talking to you.
It's been such a lot of fun.
I don't know how long this has
gone on for but [INAUDIBLE].
TRISHA GEE: It's been fun.
MANDY WAITE: So that's
awesome.
OK.
So that's the end of our session
with Trisha Gee.
Thanks for joining us.
And look out for more sessions
from the UK Women Techmakers.
EMMA JACKSON: From
Campus London.
Thanks.
MANDY WAITE: Cheers.
Bye-bye.
Fantastic.